let's start maybe with uh like a little
bit of just market structure in general
the last two years has been pretty
incredible for bitcoin obviously you
know the start of 2020 was kind of
around eight ten thousand dollars ran
all the way up to 69 000 back in
november
what's your general read on like maybe
why some of that occurred and how much
of it is like bitcoin or crypto market
stuff versus just you know the fed
stepped in it was going to pump asset
prices and bitcoins volatile so it went
up
yeah if i was going to boil it down to
one thing well i guess it would be like
two sort of market adages one is don't
fight the fed
and the other one is it's all one trade
okay and don't don't fight the feds been
around for
at least a decade
and
uh it's all one trade it's been around
for the last two years
and and basically what both of those
kind of speak to is the same backdrop
which is
central bank actions
in the current monetary regime
have such an overwhelming
overwhelmingly powerful impact on all
asset prices
that basically everything else is is
almost just an afterthought and that was
the backdrop for
the run-up after the covet crash
and that's now you know the backdrop
heading the other direction as the fed
is uh is is trying to tighten monetary
policy yeah i i tend to agree that that
is a uh uh a huge driver if not the the
only thing really to pay attention to
right here uh what i want to do today is
talk about bitcoin but i want to use it
as kind of a discussion point for more
of like the macro environment and a lot
of the stuff that's going on there uh if
you subscribe to this idea of it is all
one trade bitcoin to me seems like it's
the most pure macro asset maybe uh but
it's still part of this kind of larger
legacy financial market and so you sent
out a recent update we've pulled a
couple of the uh charts out of there
that i thought just were home runs
frankly uh and the first one and i
thought it was very telling this was
like the first thing that you led with
was the price of bitcoin and you
overlaid a tweet uh on top of it and the
tweet uh says the former new york fed
governor dudley if stocks don't fall the
fed needs to force them and it was
citing a cnbc uh interview and that was
back in kind of early april which
obviously was part of this like price
relief rally after bitcoin had dropped
50 percent and so talk to me a little
bit about this like mentality coming
from the fed whether active officials or
former officials of like they seem to
think that they are in control and they
know exactly what they're doing
yes i think there's there's two things i
speak to about that chart the first one
is just how tightly
nasdaq and bitcoin are trading with each
other and you can just see that they're
overlaid uh on top of one another and
they look like exactly the same
and then the second thing that i added
was was that tweet
uh
which was was basically a former fed
governor
writing a bloomberg
op-ed article that was entitled like the
like what it says in that tweet if if
stocks don't fall the fed should force
them to fall
which is
uh you know a pretty crazy thing for
these boomers to be running around
saying
but they are
dead set on fighting inflation they're
terrified of inflation
inflation is um
you know the hot button political item
uh the fed has become deeply politicized
the the the notion of an independent
uh federal reserve i think is is a joke
at this point
and
uh
and and and so
the the the fed has a few different
mechanisms that they think through
uh trying to
sort of tame inflation with
but but one of them is through this
mechanism called financial conditions
and there's an index you can type into
tradingview or bloomberg the financial
conditions index which is a combination
of a few different things but
two of the inputs in into
financial conditions are uh equity
prices and uh debt prices fixed income
prices
and and so one way to tighten financial
conditions is to
make
stocks this price of stocks fall uh make
the price of bonds fall
and by doing so
the fed has this view that
through sort of wealth effect
people's net worth is going down because
they're long stocks they're long bonds
the prices of those are going down their
net worth is going down as their net
worth is going down it makes them
uh buy less things uh spend less money
and then that has a you know uh an
effect of obtaining inflation over time
and so that that was that was really
what what dudley was speaking to
and and other other fed officials as
well too
and and and so it's in the it gets you
into this pretty
you know kind of creepy
spot of
um
you know the fed feeling like the best
way for them to try and get inflation
under control is to just hit everybody's
net worth and they can do that with
uh you know maximum jawboning uh and
then how much of that jawbone you know
so job owning is just this term of like
you know talking
a big game about something and then how
much of that talk actually translates
into
action then sort of remains to be seen
and is what's going to be
front and center over the coming months
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time